plus de 23 ans moins de 70 inscrits sur
les listes électorales
les critères sont entrés pour peut-être
devenir jurée d'assises et répondre à la
question fatidique coupable ou non
coupable à guyancourt on a procédé à ce
tirage au sort obligatoires soixante six
électeurs sur plus de 17000 ont été
présélectionnés la première étape d'un
long procédé dans un premier temps la
commune va prévenir les les inscrire en
envoyant un courrier comme quoi ils font
partie des soixante six présélectionnés
pour le jury d'assises en leur précisant
qu' il se peut très bien qu'il ne soit
pas retenue par le tribunal
ensuite la cour d'assises sélectionne
1084 personnes dans tout le département
en éliminant les personnes condamnées
pour crime ou délit
celle qui occupe des fonctions
incompatibles avec celles de jurés ou
les proches des magistrats et des
accusés au final seuls six jurés siège
aux assises les procès se tienne en
moyenne tous les trois mois pendant
quinze jours
et si vous êtes sélectionné impossible
de refuser sauf en cas de maladie grave
ou si vous n'habitez plus dans le
département à saint quentin en yvelines
salle voisins-le-bretonneux
montigny-le-bretonneux et elancourt
n'ont pas encore procédé au tirage au
sort
les communes ont jusqu'au 15 juillet